first time that you and I met I was with
my wife and afterwards were driving home
yeah and we had just met you and my wife
says I have such a girl-crush on
Elizabeth Banks and I felt like that's
kind of you know a nice very nice from
one woman to another she was just so
taken with you I love her yeah your wife
Liza yeah we're in love yeah I don't
know I'm just giving you the update you
too really it works out really yeah all
right no thank you
okay thanks for the intro as long as I
get to hang around I'm married too so
it's a foursome oh oh yeah oh yeah oh
well I'll do it College you know it's
funny guys don't say I've got a guy
crush on that guy it's a funny thing
I've heard women say oh I have such a
girl-crush on her and they feel
confident doing it but no guy says I've
got such a guy crush right exactly
but yeah guy says I've got a crush on
that other side and crush cuz that seems
way more tough yeah boy crush right
they're not gonna want a bromance no
it's not a bromance a guy crush seems
less threatening sometimes I feel like
my husband you know I'm I don't know I
think he'd do it with Tom Brady right
like who wouldn't your husband would do
it with Tom Brady I don't know if Tom
Brady were into it you know what I think
I would do yeah I'm from Boston you're
from Boston I would I think I would yeah
I think I would yeah I definitely think
I would sleep with Tom Brady I'm that
again I don't know why you wouldn't yeah
okay well so they're both man man yeah I
don't know I do it just to get it that
Giselle yeah
yeah
Tom Brady but looking over it - yeah
I'll be over there in a minute I know
you want some of this fashion this is
how I kiss by the way
[Laughter]
you